in the aftermath of both the Kyle
Rittenhouse trial and the trial over the
killing of Ahmad arbory now the jilane
Maxwell trial has started and this is
the trial over uh jillane Maxwell
colloquially believed to be sort of like
the fixer for much of the sexual assault
that the late Jeffrey Epstein was
involved in uh Julian Maxwell both his
girlfriend and also sort of uh you know
that a lot of this is allegations that
that are being explored but believed to
be accused of being
um someone who helped groom and get uh
women into this kind of um perverse
alleged system of abuse that Epstein
perpetuated and um in the last few days
folks including like Lauren bobert the
Republican congresswoman who's vile I
mean just vile disgusting woman
made a big deal of saying the left is
worried about this trial because a lot
of leftists are going to be exposed for
maybe being involved with Jeffrey
Epstein
um well yesterday Jeffrey Epstein's
former airplane pilot testified and
named Donald Trump as a passenger on
Epstein's what was sometimes called
shockingly the Lolita Express also
naming Bill Clinton the point here is
not that this doesn't hit Democrats and
Republicans but rather that it basically
just involves a powerful men who want to
be around rich people powerful people
and young attractive women quite frankly
and so this is potentially not going to
go well for a lot of different people a
bunch of interesting reports including
this one from Newsweek which says Trump
Clinton among famous Flyers no sex acts
seen on Jeffrey Epstein's jet pilate
says
um Jeffrey Epstein's former pilot
testified Tuesday in the sex trafficking
trial of Chilean Maxwell saying he never
saw any evidence of sexual activity when
he was flying Epstein's plane
um you know that could be meaningful or
not oftentimes the pilots don't leave
the cockpit during uh during these
flights which are often just a few hours
um the Associated Press reported that
Lawrence Paul vasovsky Jr was Epstein's
pilot for nearly 30 years piloted around
a thousand flights between 91 and 2019.
he said he flew famous people such as
prince Andrew whose association with
Epstein was already known former U.S
President Bill Clinton and Donald Trump
Maxwell has been accused of recruiting
and grooming girls that Epstein was
accused of sexually abusing for at least
10 years starting in 2004 vasovsky said
in the hierarchy of Epstein's World
Maxwell was the number two while Epstein
was the big number one some media
members have called Epstein's plane the
Lolita Express after allegations
surfaced he used it to fly teen girls to
his properties though visotsky says Ah
he stayed in the cockpit for the
majority of the flights he said Epstein
never warned him to stay there and
encouraged him to use the bathroom in
the back which would require him to walk
through the length of the plane when
Maxwell's attorney Christian everdel
asked visosky if he had ever seen sexual
activity or toys on the plane he said
never he also said he had absolutely not
seen any sexual activity with underage
girls on the plane adding he had also
never seen children on the plane who
were not with their parents
uh whenever doll asked about a teenager
who prosecutors say was sexually abused
by Epstein before she became an adult
visowski said he believed she was mature
when he was introduced to her he also
acknowledged that Bill Clinton was a
passenger on a few flights in the 2000s
had piloted planes with Britain's prince
Andrew the late U.S senator John Glenn
and former president Donald Trump and
Bill Clinton more than once more than
once
um so listen uh this is being made out
to be uh partisan the right is saying
this was a democratic sexual assault
party plane Bill Clinton
Etc uh some on the left are saying it's
Trump who was really the guy here it's
everybody guys and it's everybody who
was on the planes rep Republicans and
Democrats in terms of sexual assault we
don't know now it should be said and I
want to be really careful how I say it
there have been allegations
made against Epstein and Trump
as a what's the even word as a team I
mean I don't even know what to say
um about what I believe would qualify as
gang rape of a minor that that's an
allegation that has been made
um but charges have been dropped and
there's a lot of complication about it
but we've seen the video of Donald Trump
and Jeffrey Epstein at a party sort of
like evaluating and raiding women who
were dancing based on the video we don't
have any evidence that those women were
underage they all appear to have been of
age but uh my instinct is there's a lot
of people wrapped up with this and
um I don't believe that it is a partisan
thing and we're going to see what comes
out now a lot of people have gotten very
conspiratorial saying whoa on the first
day of sheilane Maxwell's trial
Jack Dorsey steps down as CEO of Twitter
there's no evidence whatsoever that the
two things are related another one is
the day Omicron is announced the jilayan
Maxwell trial starts actually that's not
even true the trial started Monday
Omicron sort of became National global
news on Friday it does doesn't even
really make sense
um that being said
um without going any further of course
if jelane Maxwell is found dead by
Suicide
I will be wondering about that that
would be very very strange and um
okay yeah I mean you know that's the
email I get most frequently David will
you will you concede that if jealaine
Maxwell takes her own life that it would
be strange yeah I mean it hasn't
happened it's a hypothetical it has not
happened but yes that would be a strange
thing this is bipartisan trouble quite
frankly and it doesn't look like it's
going to stop anytime soon